j'espère que vous avez pas pensé que je
vous raconte des mensonges maintenant ça
met un peu de pression
en fait moi je veux venir vous parler de
quelque chose qui me déprime
profondément c'est la pollution
il y en a partout dans notre
environnement mais rassurez vous je suis
pas quelqu'un de pessimiste automobile
doit et du côté des solutions ce qui me
réjouit beaucoup plus à aborder avec
vous comme problématique aujourd'hui je
présente dans un premier temps un
paysage vert c'est bucolique
c'est verdoyant et des petits nuages
vraiment j'aurais envie d'aller gambader
en plein milieu de la prairie si puceau
qui en a quelques-uns parmi vous qui
viendraient me suivre donc parmi les
solutions que je veux représenter
aujourd'hui je vais parler en
particulier de la phytoremédiation et je
vais vous définir ça dans quelques
instants
si on a de la pollution et conques
analyse cette pollution là par exemple
dans un égout ça va être relativement
simple de filtrer l'eau de mettre une
usine de traitement et de s'en
débarrasser en fait les êtres humains et
ingénieux pour envoyer de la pollution
un peu partout mais on utilise souvent
l'ingénierie pour venir à bout de nos
problèmes de pollution si on contamine
par contre un écosystème il va falloir
encore utiliser de l'ingénierie mais au
lieu d'avoir une usine de traitement
vont refuser une pompe pièces et
d'enlever le plus possible du
contaminant qu'on aurait pendu dans
notre environnement
par contre si le sol est contaminé mais
l'oeil vaut carrément falloir aller
faire ce qu'on appelle en bon français
du dégaine jump ce que ça veut dire
on excavés quelque part ce qui est
contaminée et ont le don ailleurs fait
un peu déplacé le problème parfois on
est capable de traiter le seul excavés
mai
pas tout le temps donc c'est une
solution assez drastiques ça décoiffe un
peu le paysage comme vous pouvez voir en
arrière c'est très coûteux
ça va être bon dans une situation
d'urgence mais pas tout le temps donc
imaginez vous que vous êtes dans le
grand nord il n'y a pas de route d'accès
vous faites quoi vous prenez un
hélicoptère pour amener l'excavatrice
vous partez votre terre avec une
excavatrice pour l'amener plus loin
c'est pas durable c'est pas une solution
qui fonctionne bien quand on est en
région éloignée et de plus en plus on
transporte des produits chimiques des
contaminants que ce soit du pétrole ou
d'autres produits dans des régions sur
de vastes étendues de terres que ce soit
par train par pipeline aussi et on a un
fort potentiel de contaminer des
endroits de plus en plus difficiles
d'accès évidemment il ya des groupes
environnementalistes qui vont nous dire
arrêter il faut limiter notre dépendance
au pétrole arrêté de transporter s'est
produit un peu partout mais la société
est pas encore rendu à avoir
complètement éliminer les sources de
pollution
donc qu'est ce qu'on doit faire en
attendant il faut trouver d'autres
méthodes créatives de venir à endiguer
la pollution qu'on met dans notre
environnement
que ce soit des produits pétroliers des
produits comme des pesticides des
produits synthétiques
on veut des contaminés et au lieu de
toujours se tourner par l'ingénierie
c'est quand même intéressante de se
tourner vers ce que la nature fait parce
que la nature fait bien les choses
donc revenons à notre paysage agricole
cib aussi bucolique
imaginez-vous cas chaque année ce sont
pas des déversements accidentels de
produits chimiques qui se déroule dans
ce paysage typiquement mais bien des
versements volontaires
d'accord les concentrations sont
peut-être moins élevé que qu'un train se
fracasse puits déverse tout son pétrole
d'un seul coup mais néanmoins sur des
grandes étendues tard on va mettre des
petites quantités de fertilisants ou de
pesticides qui vont finir vraiment pas
polluer l'écosystème si c'est pas bien
contrôlé prenez par exemple les
fertilisants un excès de fertilisants
s'il est pas entièrement captée par les
plantes qui poussent dans ce sens va
finir par ruisseler vers les cours d'eau
rendu là va favoriser la prolifération
d'algues
certains de ces algues peuvent même
produire des tonnes
et ça va être nuisible pour les poissons
dans l'écosystème ne sait même pas
toutes les allées qui sont nuisibles en
fait la chose qu'elles ont en commun par
contre ceux qui ne sont pas une durée de
vie indéfinie et qu'en live et vont
mourir et des microbes qui vont
s'attaquer à son corps pour la
décomposer et ses microbes l'eau sont
tellement actif qui vont capter une
bonne partie de l'oxygène que dans
l'écosystème ça peut même devenir une
mort complètement anoxique ait pu assez
d'oxygène pour que les poissons survivre
ça se produit dans les ruisseaux dans
les fleuves et même jusqu'à l'océan
donc c'est pas heureux d'avoir trop de
nutriments de fertilisants qui ruisselle
vers les cours d'eau agricole les
pesticides maintenant depuis la
révolution industrielle les pistes qui
nous ont vraiment aidé à augmenter les
rendements du moins c'est la conclusion
qu'en tire la majorité des personnes
mais peut-être parmi vous il y en a qui
ont l'âge de se souvenir c'est pas mon
cas de rupture personnes qui avaient
écrit le livre printemps silencieux pour
décrier la problématique des pesticides
vraiment très toxique et très persistant
dans l'environnement depuis ce temps là
on a mis en oeuvre le développement de
plusieurs autres pesticides de synthèse
qui sont beaucoup moins toxiques et
persistants dans l'environnement
je vous mentionne deux exemples le
premier un insecticide la famille des
pyréthrinoïdes 6 1,6 et là on les
utilise abondamment fait si le choix
numéro 1 si vous avez un envahisseur
domestique que vous voulez éradiquer
avant qui vous mange la tête comme c'est
le cas ici les pyréthrinoïdes ont dit
qu'ils sont faiblement persistant dans
l'environnement
c'est vrai ils se dégradent beaucoup
plus rapidement que le ddt par exemple
par contre ces pesticides si on le met
dans un milieu fermé comme un silo à
grains et peut persister jusqu'à un an
et oui il est vraiment moins toxique que
les insecticides qui le remplace et
d'une façon chronique et gül à court
terme
ça va être moins toxiques nec d'une
façon chronique à long terme à petites
doses
on a découvert par exemple qui pouvait
atteindre la fertilité atteindre le
développement intellectuel chez les
enfants même causer des cancers
donc c'est pas parce qu'ils sont moins
toxiques qu'ils ne sont pas toxiques
prenons un autre exemple le glyphe
auxerre le glyphosate vous le connaissez
peut-être déjà mais vous connaissez pas
le nom de la molécule chimique le rwanda
commercialisés par monsanto depuis les
années 70 ça a révolutionné la façon que
les agriculteurs font de l'agriculture
aujourd'hui on dit que ça augmente
vraiment les rendements enfin
l'utilisateur les sauces
vous pourriez aussi bien l'utiliser dans
l'entrée de garage devant chez vous pour
vous attaquer aux mauvaises herbes que
pour faire sécher les graines blé dans
un champ avant la récolte dans leurs
vergers de pommes dans un verger
d'orange mais l'endroit où on utilise le
plus abondamment est vraiment dans
toutes les sphères on peut utiliser le
glyphosate
ça va être dans la culture du maïs et du
soya qui sont génétiquement modifiées
pour y résister
ce que vous voyez sur l'image ci un
plant de maïs et ce plan mais cela il
est très verdoyante pourtant vais juste
d'appliquer des façades dessus mais lui
on a changé son code génétique pour
qu'ils puissent y résister la mauvaise
herbe à côté par contre pas aussi
chanceuse et se marrent et ça fait le
bonheur des agriculteurs parce qu'ils
refusent de compétition entre le maïs et
la mauvaise herbe
mais qu'est ce qui arrive quand on met
ce festival dans l'environnement baisse
à cause encore une fois des problèmes de
santé
il ya une grande agence internationale
qui vient de classer le glyphosate comme
cancérigène le mois dernier vous
imaginez que chez monsanto ça brasse pas
pour trouver une contre-étude à la
question donc il ya des gens qui
voudraient encore une fois bannir les
pesticides de synthèse milieu agricole
on n'est pas encore rendu là donc qu'est
ce qu'on fait on se tombe barre des
solutions et c'est ici que je vais
introduire le sujet des
phytotechnologies phyto
c'est très simple un grec ça veut dire
plan donc transformer les plantes pour
les faire travailler pour nous c'est
quand même pratique je vous mentionne le
premier exemple imaginez vous êtes le
long d'une autoroute
vous vous rendez dans nos offres phares
du ski et vous voyez des maisons juste à
côté de l'autoroute
ils doivent pas dormir très bien donc
parfois on va construire des murs
pour empêcher la pollution sonore on
peut faire des murs vivants qui sont
vraiment efficaces
en plus d'être esthétique et autre chose
que ces morts vivants là peuvent faire
séquestrer le carbone
c'est une des plus grandes
problématiques de l'humanité est en ce
moment là les changements climatiques et
si les plantes peuvent prendre le
carbone que dans l'atmosphère il
fixement leur bois et bien on est
gagnant
est ce que je vais vous parler ce dont
je vais vous parler aujourd'hui c'est
plutôt de la phytoremédiation donc on
revient nos histoires de pollution
environnementale
la future et médiation en fait c'est
d'utiliser la plante comme outil de
décontamination
que ce soit pour l'eau pour le sol ou
même parfois pour l'air jusque-là
planter vos faire ce qu'elle va absorber
les contaminants qui sont dissous dans
l'eau elle va les prendre dans son corps
si par exemple vous avez un énorme
camion qui va vaporiser un champ avec
des herbicides la plante peut aussi
intercepter les gouttelettes
d'herbicides avant qu'elle se rendait au
ruisseau voisin
c'est assez bénéfique et un couple et
polluants sont rendus dans le corps de
la plante
laplante volée
séquestré soit les gardes est fixé dans
ses feuilles dans ses branches et puis
aussi carrément brisé les molécules par
son métabolisme et peut aussi faire de
la volatilisation si vous prenez un
polluant qui est volatile la plante le
prend dans son corps ça passe dans les
feuilles se suivent à part dans
l'atmosphère donc ça nettoie votre sol
évidemment les plans de travail
possibles et vont travailler en étroite
association avec une panoplie de
micro-organismes que ce soit des
bactéries ou des champignons qui vont
faire une bonne partie du travail de
décontamination
je présente la molécule de glyphosate
ici et notre ami le microbe qui va aller
dégrader la molécule pour la rendre un
peu moins toxiques
mais l'autre pensez pas que toutes ces
organismes le pont ce travail là pour
notre bon plaisir en sentant la plante a
besoin de décontaminer son environnement
pourquoi intoxiqué et le microbe
cherchent à manger quelque chose au
québec on a mis de l'avant une politique
qui requiert le respect de la végétation
en bordure de tous les cours d'eau
agricole sur une largeur d'au moins
trois mètres
on appelle cet espace-là la bande
riveraine et c'est une phytotechnologies
qui nous permet de décontaminer la
pollution diffuse qui est récurrente
dans les milieux agricoles s'agit
littéralement comme un filtre contre la
pollution
mais la science est formel plus la bande
riveraine est large plus il est efficace
alors pourquoi on a choisi un compromis
de 3 m est ce que ça fonctionne pas
vraiment personne qu'ils sont donc
grands groupes de chercheurs professeurs
étudiants associés s'est penché sur la
question
c'est une équipe multidisciplinaire avec
des biologistes des chimistes mais au
gîte aussi déjà des chances sociale si
vous dites à l'agriculteur ça vous prend
une bande riveraine
mais qui en veut pas faut comprendre
pourquoi que ça vient d'où donc parmi
les personnages qui est ici présents à
part mes illustres directeur le faut je
leur rende hommage marc lecoq michel
labrecque le personnage le plus
important ici c'est celle xme abm qui
cessa selick semi à bienne au sein sur
la croissance rapide dont l'utilisent
régulièrement pour décontaminer des
terres de l'eau est ici on veut voir ce
serait le candidat idéal pour le mettre
en bandes riveraines
on veut voir s'il serait plus efficace
en fait que la nature quand elle fait
pousser ce que les agriculteurs m
appelait affectueusement des mauvaises
herbes sur le bar de l'orge donc dans le
cadre de ma tête j'ai étudié pour voir
si les mauvaises herbes rouges ou la
friche qui peut pousser naturellement
sur le bord des ruisseaux avec des
plantes indigènes ou même des espèces
qui viennent d'ailleurs vont être moins
efficace que les soldes on va planter
très densément ou un peu moins densément
comment on fait pour mesurer
l'efficacité mais on va échantillonnés
de l'eau avant la bande riveraine après
la bande riveraine et à différentes
profondeurs pour échantillonner en
surface on utilise un équipement support
scientifique c'est une chaudière qui va
capter le ruissellement de surface un
peu plus en profondeur ses délices
mettre des tubes de plastique creux
desquels on retire entièrement l'air ça
va absorber à travers une bougie de
céramique poreuse l'eau qui se trouve
dans le sol un peu plus en profondeur
quand le sol est saturé
c'est facile on un piézomètre un grand
tuyau de plastique qui se rend jusque
dans la nappe phréatique nos
échantillons vont se décliner en une
série de petites bouteilles de toutes
les couleurs que vont nous permettre de
mesurer les nutriments les pc le carbone
qui va être dissous dans l'eau qu'est ce
qu'on observe comme résultat comme
d'autres avant nous l'ont observé la
première chose c'est qu'on diminue le
ruissellement de surface
pourquoi parce que quand les
gouttelettes d'eau arrivant surface très
rapidement et frappe la bande riveraine
ça va réduire leur vitesse
en plus les racines creuse des canaux
dans le sol ça favorise les
infiltrations la plante prendre l'eau
pour ses propres besoins mais peut aussi
créer beaucoup d'évapotranspiration donc
faire sortir
l'excès d'eau par ses feuilles l'envoyer
dans l'atmosphère ce qui veut créer un
déficit d'eau là au pied de la bande
riveraine et empêcher le ruissellement
ne rejoint les cours d'eau deuxième
chose savent aussi freiner la terre
imaginez vous une pluie intense
je suis dans le champ la pluie tombe la
pluie tombe la pluie tombe puis la plus
la dévaler la pente
apparemment cela pas comment cela tant
que monnaie va super vite ascame sur une
blanc à l'art est gratuite
les particules de terre sont déposés
juste avant la bande réforme c'est le
même processus
ensuite si c'est des nutriments dissout
par exemple les nitrates ou les
phosphates la plante on ne buzze
1 pour s'alimenter donc elle va les
absorber par ses racines et séquestré
ses nutriments la danse on boit dans son
corps donc si on procède à la récolte
des tiges on va exporter définitivement
hors du système les nutriments et
finalement j'ai parlé tout à l'heure des
microbes qui oeuvrent dans le seul qui
peuvent transformer les nitrates dissous
en une forme de gaz qui est non
dommageables ont fait se compose 70% de
notre atmosphère qu'on respire ça va
être du n 2 du diazote donc côté
pesticides comment ça fonctionne la
bande riveraine
eh bien on met notre molécule des
façades dans le champ et va se faire des
composés en partie par des microbes
d'autres partis vont s'accrocher aux
particules de terre mais il pleut
toujours au québec l'été quelques fois
il ya une partie qui va se ramasser en
direction des cours d'eau qui va se
mettre en réseau les epci rejoint des
écosystèmes sensibles ça va affecter les
animaux et ultimement nous on boit de
l'autre surface sous l'eau souterraine
on risque de s'intoxiquer avec cette eau
là donc on veut que notre bande
riveraine soit efficace
ce qu'on a observé s'il y avait beaucoup
de lift aux salles d'anchin et de
l'autre côté de la bande riveraine
il y en avait un peu moins c'est heureux
la bande riveraine fonctionne peut-être
pas suffisamment pour tout enlever par
exemple on voit que concentration qui
reste après la bande riveraine ça peut
quand même être toxique pour les animaux
donc il va falloir trouver d'autres
solutions c'est pas la panacée mais ça
nous aide
et qu'est ce qu'on a obtenu comme
conclusion c'est que la bande riveraine
et plusieurs choses qui vont affecter
son efficacité on parle toujours d'une
bande riveraine de trois mètres ici
parce que c'est ce que notre politique
provinciale nous demande mais c'est pas
tous les polluants qui vont être filtré
de la même façon si ça a fonctionné pour
le glyphosate et les nitrates c'est
heureux mais ça n'a pas fonctionné du
tout pour les phosphates dissous donc
dépendamment du type de pollution qu'on
a une même phytotechnologies ne peut pas
faire tout le travail
ça dépend aussi du site ce soir sur une
terre compactée l'eau pénètre pas
guinand seul et va avoir plus de
ruissellement surface ça fonctionne
différemment que sur un seul qui bien
drainé ulovart rentrée en profondeur à
la profondeur où les racines des plantes
peuvent faire leur effet finalement la
saison au printemps
il ya beaucoup de neige qui fond d'un
seul coup
en train de lui seulement assez intensif
de particules de fer et rodez de
nutriments de pollution sans voix par
les cours d'eau mais sinon là qu'est ce
qui se passe avec la végétation de la
bande riveraine et fait dodo est en
dormance
c'est par là qu'on va voir la plus
grande efficacité même s'il team hm
c'est à ce moment là que la plus grande
décharge de polluants qui passe depuis
les champs vers les cours d'eau est ce
qui nous a un peu surpris c'est qu'au
début je vous ai dit que le sol était si
beau si faim et pousse vite et où on
voulait vraiment on pensait qu'il serait
plus efficace que notre friche les
herbes qui poussent spontanément bordure
des champs et c'est parce qu'on a vu en
fait il était aussi efficace l'un que
l'autre
alors pourquoi un agriculteur se
donnerait le trouble de planter du sol
quand la nature qui pousse tout seul
fait déjà si bien les choses et bien
c'est potentiellement pour produire de
l'énergie
je vous présente la bande riveraine la
première année de mon projet on venait
de la taille et jusqu'au sol déjà la
deuxième année ça pousse très vite la
troisième année on a vraiment des
véritables monstres certains qui peuvent
aller jusqu'à 8 mètres de haut imaginez
si on prend tout ce sol là et qu'on le
brûle on peut faire de l'énergie avec
mais là je vous entends penser ou du 2
août à leur a dit de séquestrer le
carbone de l'atmosphère vous réglez
problème de changement climatique plus à
nous parle de brûler les le bois vers
envoyées dans l'atmosphère à ce qu
eux-mêmes briançon a fait attendre et de
nous mentir
ben non je vous ment pas c'est ce que si
vous preniez du carbone qui dans
l'atmosphère vous le mettez dans la
plante vous le brûler vous leur envoyer
dans l'atmosphère c'est une boucle
fermée un peu c'est presque carboneutre
par contre si on revient au pétrole du
début de la présentation que vous l'ex
cave et très profondément dans la terre
vous le brûler à ce moment là vous
rajouter de nouveaux carbone dans
l'atmosphère
donc c'est toutes les considérations à
prendre en compte quand on utilise les
phytotechnologies la phytoremédiation
avec les plantes
alors il nous reste vraiment beaucoup de
chemin à parcourir pour protéger
adéquatement notre environnement mais
j'aimerais que tout le monde ici
aujourd'hui se souviennent que les
plantes peuvent jouer un rôle vraiment
très importante pour nous aider je
remercie beaucoup
merci l'oif